but first the kids aren't all right
that's the focus of tonight's angle
about three quarters of the world's
school children are
not in school and they're not there
because of covet 19. it affects about
1.5 billion children and young people
i've searched and i can't find any
example of this ever having happened
anywhere else in the modern world not in
history
now few disagree that prolonged absence
from the classroom has profound
implications for children's well-being
their development
and their knowledge retention last
friday one of the most renowned
pediatric specialists in the world
expressed his deep concern on this show
about the harm this is causing
we know from studies now out of china
that depression rates in kids who've
been
locked down are up 20 to 30 percent
we know that children from low
low-income families in particular
who are being homeschooled they're not
getting an adequate education
because their parents are working
because they don't have high-speed
internet
and those kids are falling further and
further behind
at-risk kids especially vulnerable
certainly that makes sense
but almost all moms with whom i speak
are frustrated
and they're frankly frightened that
these closures are going to continue
indefinitely now whether parents work
outside or inside
the home or their stay-at-home parents
now most
are not well suited to be teaching an
array of subjects
especially if they have multiple
children and by the way the teachers
don't seem all that thrilled either
all of my kids in my classroom are all
laughing and there's talking and there's
movement and busyness
and i've gone from that to a totally
different
thing where i'm an i.t person looking at
a screen all day and i'm just trying to
help
parents on with tech issues all day long
okay i've been there guilty as charged
trying to figure out the tech issues
now digital learning distance learning
online classes
they they have a place and they may work
as supplements or in very short periods
of time
but it all gets old fast and it leads in
some cases to
a feeling of isolation and it just
doesn't engage children like in-person
learning
yet 192 countries pulled kids out of
school
and these decisions were based not so
much on science
but out of an abundance of caution you
really can't blame people everyone was
worried they're freaking out they don't
want anything to happen to their kids
so what do we know now about the how
health risks though to children and
and to adults if they return to school
well we know now that overwhelmingly
children do not get seriously ill from
covid thank goodness
most testing positive are totally
asymptomatic
recently health officials are reporting
instances though
of an inflammatory reaction in kids that
could be covered related
although it is also rarely fatal
the real debate right now surrounds how
much if at all
children spread the virus to adults the
idea that they're
silent super spreaders that sounded
really scary some weeks ago but that's
basically been debunked
more research is really needed yet
regarding the school issue maybe we
start thinking about it this way
a comparison to influenza might be
illustrative according to the cdc's
numbers which is all we have to go by
that this past flu season
was a very bad one for children
well only a handful of children died
from covid nationwide as of may 9th
the cdc reported 174
pediatric flu deaths this season in
addition we had
18 million medical visits and 410
000 hospitalizations due to influenza
this season again
according to the cdc on its website the
cdc estimates between
this is curious twenty four thousand
and sixty two thousand preliminary flu
deaths
that's quite a range it's complicated i
guess to get
all the states turning in all their data
but that's a big range could be
as many as 62 000. why didn't we hear
more about the flu
vis-a-vis kids in school given that
number
even with the double-barrel threat of
influenza a
and influenza b which kids are really
susceptible this season
and the fact that it's highly contagious
among classmates
we had no wide scale school closures in
the united states i didn't even hear of
anyone suggesting that
even during the swine flu epidemic only
about 726
of the more than 131 000 k through 12
schools in the country shut down
now i'm not saying that covert 19 by the
way is like the flu it is not
but what i am saying is that far more
children died of influenza this year
that it's highly contagious among them
yet no one seriously considered keeping
most of our nation's school children at
home
because of the danger now last month the
lancet
published a review of past coronavirus
studies
and it suggests that closing schools may
only have a minor role
in suppressing covet 19. now they looked
at the data from sars and that outbreak
in mainland china hong kong and
singapore and it suggests that school
transmission played no trans a
substantial role
in the outbreak and that school closures
and other activities such as school
temperature monitoring
did not contribute to control of
infection transmission
we'll see how it goes i guess with covet
19 but it's certainly worth noting that
now in sweden school children there
were never pulled from school and
meanwhile the guardian reports that
reopening of schools in 22 european
countries now
has not led to any significant increase
in coronavirus infections among children
among parents or staff now there was a
thing in france we had 70 people in an
outbreak but
out of the huge number of people back in
school there they have a handle on that
now
today i went on a two-hour bike ride
through dc with my 11 year old i went
through the woods
went through parts of the city and all
four of us go on these long walks
in the woods most mornings oh my kids
and i
and that's been a treat for me and and
for them usually although sometimes they
roll their eyes at me but that's just
the way it goes
now these are memories that i cherish
because they're home from school we can
do that
yet i have to say i'm really worried
about how much they've really learned
this semester
even how great their teachers are it's
still not the same and i
see how much they miss their friends and
their teachers
and the administrators at their schools
and i'm also thinking and we pray for
this every night about the less
fortunate among us
they don't have any help they don't have
the luxury of venturing into nature
every day perhaps
and what about the front line workers
they can't find child care or someone to
supplement the teaching of their kids
what happens if unemployed people
in the fall find jobs we hope they do
yet their kids schools say sorry they're
not coming back
we need to get creative and not abandon
classroom learning
certainly since we don't have any real
data to back this up
now check this out cambridge university
has basically given up
and they've announced that they're not
opening until i think the summer of 2021
at this point
but we can be smarter and are notre dame
just announced that it's opening in the
fall but they're going to end their
semester a little bit early and they're
going to kill the fall break i don't
know why they have the fall
break anywhere there but they are
killing that in case there's a second
wave so they're
you know moderating but they're getting
people back
kids need school at all all ages we can
protect their health
and we can protect their minds we can
use our innovation
and we can use our common sense and no
i'm sorry zoom
is not the answer and that's the angle